what kind of money were you making at
the time i mean again it's 1988 and i'm
making probably 50 000 a month in 88
you're making 15. i'm 21 years old it's
a lot of money now you're 21 years old
what's life like are you have you
started partying or not yet i'm still
living at home i'm a kid
the partying thing wasn't that important
to me because me and my wife who's my
wife now
uh we've been together since i was 17.
so i was already on my way to you know
trying to get focused on getting engaged
and having a family so partying wasn't
important to me establishing the career
was primary 37 years you've been
together with your wife that's correct
that's unbelievable four children that's
incredible changing in age from 26 to
nine holy moly good so you're still
working good for you hard-working family
so you're making 50 a month you're 21
you're not a party guy you're staying
home you and your wife you've been
together since 17
you know you become the branch manager
five months later you're you're doing
your thing jordan leaves he resigns at
that okay so go from there sometimes
jordan leaves it's a mass exodus at that
point now the mob influence that was
there was a legendary gambito gangster
by the name of joe butch correa
he was working there no of course not
he's a major gangster but the firm is on
record with him okay so the way it went
down is there are
two principles of the firm their names
were freddie gagliardo and johnny
perfetti
and the two of them the way they dressed
the way they looked the way they carried
themselves you could see gangster
personification
so this was my first direct association
as you know a businessman with the mob
although it's been an influence in me
since i'm a baby now it's directly with
me and i'm running the show here so what
happens is the security regulators ban
them from the industry so they get asked
to leave this is fd roberts yes okay so
after they stepped down a fellow down
here in florida by the name of lenny
tucker legendary trader he steps in as
chairman and he's the one that promotes
me the branch office matters so fd
roberts stays intact yeah except the the
people that were involved with the mob
they step away they had to they were
banned from the industry got it okay and
i guess the prerequisite was the firm to
remain open if those two fellows step
away makes sense so joe butch carrajo's
son vincent was an employee there the
day i met him i said what do you do for
a living big guy too he shows me his
business card he said assistant to the
chairman of the board i said okay
so i looked at this i said i'm gonna
take this place over this is mine i'm
italian nobody can work like i do nobody
knows this industry like i do this was
built for me i had one requisite and
that's i want to open up in lower
manhattan i want to be on wall street so
ultimately we do open up on wall street
we were there two months the feds raided
the place the place was closed down and
that was the end of that so the whole
thing lasted maybe 14 15 months so the
50 came out lasted 14 15 months at 21.
did you do time or no no no i was not
party to any any criminal liability
because my time there we had done no
initial public offerings no ipos at that
time were you licensed are you serious i
was like okay i got my license there you
got your license at fd roberts okay so
you go to lower manhattan your you want
your branch couple months later boom
what happens next we're overlooking the
hudson we had the most gorgeous office
we were ready to rock and roll and then
it ended when it did end
i was skiing up in hunter mountain in
upstate new york and i got a call from
my mother who told me that the fbi had
just come to the house wanting to talk
to me telling her tell your son to get
home immediately he's going to be
indicted this is for fd roberts
i get an attorney i go to two gateway
plaza in newark new jersey
and i walk in there are three fbi agents
two agents for the securities exchange
commission two from the nasd
two postal inspectors and two
representatives from new jersey bureau
securities so they get me in this room
and they cornered me asking me to wear a
wire to testify against freddie
gagliardo joe butch correao johnny
perfetti and i said am i being charged
today with anything and they said no i
said conversation's over got up walked
out never heard another word so it was a
bluff i called him out on the bluff and
i was fine so next after i leave fd
roberts
and this is where jordan and i are
passed across again interesting enough
if you if you looked at a breakdown of
my securities license you'll see after
fd roberts there were two other firms
that i signed on for as i signed on both
of them subsequently closed within days
of me going there so i said okay i'm
done with the small firms i'm going back
to the big firms there was a major wall
street firm been around 100 years called
gruntle
gruntal at the time was the third
largest insurance company in the world
insurance company yes but they had a
broken dealer got it so i went to work
in an office there i get a call from
barry gesser
barry gesser's jordan belford's
right-hand man
at oak at stratton or i didn't know at
the time
but i believe it was stratton's security
it's owned by a fellow by the name of
jim taramina
barry calls me cesaro what are you doing
you're at gruntal are you crazy
gruntle's like merrill lynch you can't
own merrill lynch
let me tell you what i'm doing you
remember jordan so i said yeah he said
okay i'm buying stratton securities
jordan's buying a company called oakmont
out in long island we're going to merge
the companies we want you to own we want
you to run the manhattan operation with
the possibility of being national sales
manager i said let me come meet you i
drive into manhattan he's working at i'm
sorry he's living at trump park which
made an impression on me who's he jordan
is barry gesser i never see jordan nor
do i talk to him and i never did to this
day so i drive to trump park barry's in
his apartment i walk in and i said barry
there's no way in the world you're
getting me this early unless you pay me
up front he says what do you want i said
35 000 cash upfront he says done meet me
at the office tomorrow we'll go over all
the terms i went there i signed an
agreement he gave me the check i said
i'll start on monday i deposited the
check in those days checks took forever
to cash
ultimately i start on monday on tuesday
to check bounces
i says barry you got to be kidding me
man how do you let this check bounce i
mean i'll leave in three seconds you
gotta make good on this
ultimately he gives me another check or
i redeposit it i don't remember it
bounces again now he's with jordan in an
office in long island i drive there like
a raving lunatic
and i'm banging on doors nobody will see
me nobody will talk to me i take a bat i
go under the building into the garage
where his little red mercedes
convertible is and i beat that car from
beginning to end from from the sides to
the windows to the mirrors and just
destroyed the car
left and never again heard from burying
us or jordan belford again as i was in
and i had no dealings with jordan there
only barry
that's literally the story that is the
truth okay 1989. so 89 at this point so
the 35 000 check bounces twice
you go destroy car they go on to merge
stratton oakmont and then become
stratton oakmont
he's blown up yet has jordan blown up
here
to be honest with you i don't even know
and i'm not bad mouthing anybody and i'm
not starting any fights
i've never even heard of that i don't
even know what they did it wasn't like
you know the most popular firm on the
street they were buried in long island
doing their thing
you know but the wolf of wall street i
don't i don't know anything you've seen
a movie though yeah of course okay so
you didn't know nothing about the
stories of the parties any of that stuff
no but that was the norm that was going
on but you were not on the scene either
so it's not like you were in the same
party and because you were more a guy
that was a married guy my office was
okay i got you once i blew up and did my
thing like we did the bowling
that was you yeah but whether or not he
did it too i can't tell you whether he
did i remember a couple of my guys heard
it on howard stern because howard stern
had the mitch bowler so
they they had a party one day in the
office and they did it and i remember
that
the dwarfs with the helmets on they kept
banging into the elevator so these guys
were all crazy so i was around it i just
didn't encourage it promoted or
participated but you guys did it all of
them did it yeah we had a we got to be
honest what was it what would you you
pay these you pay them to do it like you
how does that work it's like hey there
was 200 bucks to there was a service
that provided this that's a business
model yeah so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye